hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over the
flashiest and the most flamboyant
character in all of demon slayer this
man here is so confident and powerful
that he proclaims himself to literally
be a god this here is no one else than
the master of sound himself the
strongest hishera tengan uzui
but just before we get into tenkan if
you are new around here and want to
watch other anime content just like this
then be sure to hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as well as it really helps
out with the algorithm and pushes my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
also
there's going to be spoilers in this
video so you should probably watch out
for those but anyway enough of that
let's get into this video
so who is tengen uzui voltengen was one
of nine siblings and before he became a
demon slayer and then after that a
hashera he was originally a shinobi or a
ninja which according to guitaro one of
the upper ranked kazuki or shinobi were
meant to have died out during the idol
period in japan
this here gives tingan a completely
different mindset to absolutely everyone
else inside of the demon slayer corpse
while young his family because they were
shinobi had traditionally valued
completing the mission over all owls
along with a variety of other ideals
that he grew up to know as normal like
considering someone dead if they
disappeared throughout her mission or
had not made it to the rendezvous
because of the cruel nature of his
family tenga decided to reject the
ideology that his father and remaining
brother had chosen to live by now he
believes that his subordinates whether
they be his wives or the demon slayers
under his command should value their
lives and their lives of the innocents
over their mission or his own life he
especially holds kagaya yubishiki in
high regard as someone he is
specifically thankful to for showing him
something worth actually risking his
life for because of his past uzu is very
demanding of others often treating the
demon slayers very harshly and
constantly insulting them for having no
substance even though that isn't
necessarily his intention when we first
meet tengan at the beginning of the
entertainment district he comes across
as an extremely eccentric and flashy
individual always wanting to be
flamboyant he seemed to be extremely
arrogant and would often boastfully talk
about himself however tenkan also has a
caring side that is masked under his
flamboyant facade one he only shows to
those that are extremely close to him
most notably his three wives makio suma
and hinatsudu oh yeah i probably should
mention that he's completely out of
sigma lord who was literally dripped out
in diamonds and gold not to mention the
fact that he has like three wives like
three wives man like damn chill dude
zenitz who's out here struggling to get
one and this man's got like three but
tengen usually puts on a confident front
to keep up with his boastful personality
being steadfast strong and resolute even
when he's losing or dying literally to
the point that in the midst of battle
tanjuno was reminded of kyogiro and saw
his image imitating through the aura
coming from tengen a huge reason for
this front that tengan puts up is
possibly due to the fact that he
actually has some kind of inferiority
complex as when he was told that in
comparison to the other hashera kyotaro
had killed he was actually special with
kyotaro even stating that he bet he was
special since birth this extremely
angered tengen and a telltale sign of
someone with an inferiority complex is
the refusal to participate in
competitive events for fear of being
compared to others they may also in some
scenarios attempt to overcompensate for
whatever perceived efficiency they have
by behaving in an excessively
competitive manner in other cases they
may act aggressively towards others
which is literally what tingkin does
throughout his time in the story even
though he's considered extremely good
looking he still over compensates
himself by wearing a plethora of flashy
clothing and jewelry and just as another
nail in the coffin it is further proven
by the fact that he completely denies
the possibility that he was blessed with
talent and that he tells himself that he
will never become someone as great as
kyogido
random fact about the beautiful man
himself out of every single demon slayer
that is known to us in the story both
inosuke and tengen are the only two
slayers to actually have natured in
swords instead of just a singular blade
like everyone else i meant to say jewel
and and swords silly me wating have
been her sharer of the demon slayer
corpse this automatically makes him one
of the most powerful and skilled
swordsmen in the entire corp as i said
just before tengan uses jill nurturing
cleavers which are connected by a chain
and using these cleavers he displayed
his unparalleled swordsmanship during
his battle with kyotaro even managing to
adapt to the upper rank's estranged
fighting style to compliment his large
blades tekken carries dozens of black
beads that create large explosions with
the slightest of impacts surprisingly
they are even capable of harming the
bodies of upper ranked demons tengan
uses a breathing style that he himself
created that combines his heightened
senses of hearing his musical score
technique shinobi expertise and
anti-demon bombs the style he called
sound breathing and is where he gets the
moniker of the sound hashera from
throughout the story we see him use a
variety of different abilities and
techniques that show off his raw
strength and speed the first of these
three named forms that we see from
tengen is called first form roar this
ability is extremely powerful as it
creates a ferocious force when tengan
slams his swords down while at the exact
same time creating an explosion with his
anti-demon bombs which help in dealing
grievous physical damage to the target
the ability gives off the sound
resembling a rumble of thunder or a
strike of lightning as a result
the second of the three forms that we
see tengan use is his fourth form
constant resounding slashes this form is
more of a defensive ability with a
slightly offensive counter-attack when
tenkin spins in a rapid repetition while
simultaneously releasing his bombs it
creates a massive defensive explosion
that can also damage someone if they are
within range of the bombs the third and
final of tengan's forms that we know is
his fifth form string performance with
string performance tenkan holds one of
his blades in a reverse style grip and
swings the other blade which is held up
by the chain connecting the cleavers in
a spinning motion
this coupled with also releasing a huge
amount of his bombs can cause immense
destructive damage paired with the
physical damage caused by spinning the
cleaver what makes tinker even stronger
again though is that he grew up as a
shinobi his style of fighting in general
is much more technical than most and his
senses are legs sharper than anyone
else's especially his hearing which is
like literally broken being able to
somehow hear through the ground or over
extremely long distances because of his
enhanced hearing abilities tengan was
able to learn both the musical score
technique and echolocation echolocation
is as it says in the name it's literally
like echolocation when trying to find
the location of a vessel underground
tinker analyzes the sound that gets
reflected and resonated through the air
by the walls of the caverns when he does
this he can accurately locate where he
needs to go and has even able to guess
the number of people inside the tunnels
by listening to the sound bouncing from
their physical bodies musical score
technique is super interesting in
conjunction with his sound breathing
tenkin analyzes combat maneuvers and
deconstructs the rhythm of his enemies
attacks into sound and reads them like
sheet music to the point every fight
becomes a song he then takes advantage
of this technique and listens for
so-called repeated phrases he then can
attack between beats and during the
arrests almost as if he was dancing with
his opponent and striking whenever there
is any kind of opportunity
i think this also just comes with the
territory but tengan is extremely
stealthy and has an extreme resistance
to poisons he moves so silently that he
does not make a single sound nor disturb
the air his stealth allowed him to evade
the senses of both tanjuro and inosuke
both of which have heightened sensors
here again shows off his sneakiness when
tengu was able to sneak up on and
decapitate an upper ranked demon
without her even noticing for like a few
seconds before her head fell into her
hands tengan has a crazily high
resistance to poisons to the point where
he could continue fighting while under
the effects of poison from guitardo and
not for just a short while but for
nearly the entire fight and when he
finally does succumb to the effects it
was all just a complete ruse he
purposely set up so that tenkin could
match and perfect his musical score
technique making him able to slow his
heartbeat so much that it would stop
pumping the poison around his body
another random fact about the drip god
himself is that he is one of only two
hashera to ever retire due to being
permanently disabled instead of just
simply death or old age the other was
jigoro or zenetsu's teacher who had lost
his leg back in his days as the previous
thunder heshira
well
that finally brings us to the very end
of today's video i absolutely love just
how damn cool tengen is and i personally
feel like his character really makes the
arc that he is a part of one of the best
in the entire story and that being said
if you do want to catch up on the entire
entertainment district of demon slayer
then do be sure to check out my video
where i literally like go over the
entire arc itself in pretty bad detail
but anyway it would have been nice if he
was like able to stay around a little
bit longer before he did retire as i
would have like absolutely loved to see
some more from him just in general and
uh like even possibly even find out what
his other forms could have been but at
least what we have gotten from him is
just absolutely amazing and i can
definitely rate tankin as one of if not
my favorite hashera if you guys do have
a favorite then be sure to let me know
down in the comment section below and i
can possibly go over all of them in an
upcoming video if you do want to
recommend me any videos or make any like
manga suggestions for me to get into as
well then do be sure to check out the
discord which i will leave a link to
down in the description below uh and
also if you guys do enjoy my content as
well and want to watch other stuff just
like this then be sure to hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with the algorithm and pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people but anyway enough of that for now
it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in april
bye
[Music]